welcome hello and welcome to the dork
forest it's Jackie Kashian and I am your
host at the dork force the websites
Jackie Kashian calm dork Forrest calm
the dork Forrest calm family pet
ancestry.com mostly just Jackie cachaca
and the dork force comma so a lot of you
are else is what I guess I'm saying you
know the credits the credits are Mike
Rick Berg he composed and sang the song
you just heard saying with his wife
Sarah he will sing his words to the
Mexican Hat dance at the end of the
program
Patrick Brady's gonna fix this audio
Vilmos fixes the website Jackie Kashian
comm on Jackie Kashian and dark forest
comm there is a donation button feel
free to use it if you have some money
and you like the show feel free to throw
some money to the dork forest if you
don't have any money you can go to
Jackie Kashian calm and use the amazon
banner which is just a portal to amazon
that you go to from the the white banner
at Jackie Kashian com you order like
normal from Amazon and the dork forest
gets a bit of a kick back and I thank
you for that support if you want to buy
merch you're welcome to do that you can
get t-shirts dork forests t-shirts or
Ranger of the dork Forest t-shirt or a
hoodie I still have some in stock it is
the heat of the summer of course but it
will be winter again according to the
game of thrones so you can order any of
that stuff including it's my stand-up
cds t-shirt and DVD all of that stuff is
available streaming on Amazon and iTunes
and Pandora and Spotify for free but if
you want a hard copy you get it at my
website and I will sign it if you like
you can go to band camp and get premium
episodes of the show premium episodes or
shows that are live dork forests and
they cost me a couple of bucks to make
so I charge you guys a couple of bucks
but there's always going to be a free
episode every week so don't worry about
it if you don't want to buy a lot of
episodes you're good there's also some
free content on that Bay
camp page it's the dark forest band camp
calm also on Jackie Kashian calm besides
merch and free videos of me doing
stand-up comedy and an amazon banner
there is my stand-up schedule this week
I am in New York City doing a bunch of
shows just around town you can check my
schedule you can check my Twitter at
Jackie Kashian you can email me Jackie
Jackie Kashian calm and I will tell you
where I'm playing I guess and other than
that this is a great episode so by god
let's get into it it's Jackie Kashian
minimal living room in Van Nuys is very
glamorous and welcome to the dark forest
with Rory Scovel
hello live guest hello everyone this is
my first time in Jackie Kashian home in
my living room she has provided me with
a nice coffee i want you to be fully
aware of the sounds you're gonna be
hearing i'll be partaking winter clink
yeah whoo nice ice in the glass it's uh
it's beautiful it is beautiful Rory
Scovel by the way ro ry s Co ve L if you
didn't know
and it's at Rory Scovel on everything
and is it one of my favorite stand-up
comics right now so I think you used one
of the Young Turks you know why cuz I'm
170 I am 107 guy it's gonna be pretty
sweet but I was like what do you want to
talk about you so that you are currently
slightly interested in the game of golf
you know when we've talked about doing
that before we're doing the live one
yeah I'm a little bit ago we talked
about things I was obsessed with and I
always whenever I think about stuff like
that I never like if someone like hey
tell this story or do my storytelling
show I just don't remember anything and
so it really occurred to me that I need
to start checking in with myself when
you were like hey what do you like it I
was like I don't know I don't even know
who I am and then when you brought this
what I was like oh I do know that I am
currently very self aware that I'm
obsessed with do you own your own clubs
I own my own clubs they're in the trunk
right now oh just emergent I just I just
came from the driving range and putting
just just now yeah is the dirt now my
dad used to take us through the driving
range where little is they're putting
range attached to the drivers there is
it's actually pretty nice to hear van
nuys golf course
oh the Van Nuys golf course they got a
it's a par three but they also have a 9
hole executive course which means
there's some par fours but if I say all
this stuff how knowledgeable of golf are
you do you like off you follow it well
back up because I know I took golf in
high school because I didn't have a gym
uniform was the year that I grew out of
my sister's gym yeah all the things that
didn't require a gym uniform yeah and so
here's what I know and I've also played
some video games about golf yep so there
are usually eight nine holes you can
play half a game nine holes or a full
game 18 holes that's right and and then
there there are a bunch of different
clubs there bunch of different clubs all
based on the degree that the the club is
is sitting at for instance a driver that
I use is like ten and a half degrees so
I'm going to hit that further but if I
want to just lob the ball I use like a
fifty-six degree or a 62 degree so
what's the angle it's all angles
everything it's all is it a game of
angles it's a game of numbers angles
distance I think that's what I got as a
kid if someone that would have tried to
talk me into playing golf I don't I
don't think I would have been into it I
was very into sports I was into sports
being outside running around being an
idiot right doing anything so soccer and
basketball because they're both games
that are just kind of fluid they keep
going there's not a lot of stopping I
think I was most into that cuz I'm
hyperactive okay I'm at the time I was
hyperactive so if someone would've been
like hey I want you to learn golf I
would have been like ah there's just too
much standing around it's too slow it
takes too long it's also just me where I
think I might I have enjoyed team sports
more okay so I don't think I would have
ever gotten into it no one introduced it
to me until I college okay a buddy was
like let's just go play golf and I said
yes on the whim of like cuz you're like
yeah exactly I was like yeah let's just
let's go try golf and in my head so
arrogant because I
at the time was an athlete I was like
I'll pick this up immediately and you
have to learn the hard way that it is so
difficult it's a learned skill yes what
you're telling me I mean it is the
millimeter off and your shot is
completely different you know you're in
your backswing coming through and you
don't you know if you if you lean your
back up just the slightest bit Wow your
club is gonna hit that ball way
different playing for like ten years
I have it so in okay in college we would
go play
I had my grandfather's clubs I never I
didn't take it seriously right because
we could go to the golf course get the
golf cart and I would there would be a
bunch of us and I'd be like this bunch
of gears yeah be like we all got a beers
in the car I would I would get out of
the cart I would hit whatever club my
buddy was like how far is it yeah you
should try to hit this one so I like
dialed in like oh well how far do I hit
which clubs I just didn't care I don't
want to like think about it I wasn't
ever gonna be good because it was a math
problem it was a time you get out of the
cart it's a hundred percent okay 100
percent a math problem so only now do am
I like enjoying the what is the mental
aspect of this game was like oh it's
it's less physical and more mental okay
and maybe older age for me at least
brings on the that's more appealing to
me now well I mean and it isn't I mean
there is of course there's more sitting
around as you age but the the the one
thing is is that you can see nuances
that you don't see when you're a kid
you're just like no I want to hit the
ball yeah I'm a ball hitter that's my
thing I'm a ball catcher I'm a ball
thrower yeah those are your three and as
you get older you're like but how does
this work exactly yeah so then you go
down that rabbit yeah that's interesting
and it's also you know for me who's your
your your couldn't be more average you
know if I go out to play 18 holes there
will be a few shots where someone's like
wow if they only saw those shots they
would assume I'm an amazing golf and
then there's you know I plethora of
other shots that they would see they
would be like I don't know if you've
ever played golf so I'm just like I'm so
average that I'm able to do both of
those things
and sometimes you fit right down the
middle right and so I think does that
feel like that's most everybody who
plays the game I think that is the
majority I think any when you will play
oh I think so yeah I think that's what
it is kind of blowing my mind about it
right now is that how hard it is and
miserable it can make you it still is it
has this sense of fun that is addictive
I'm kind of an OCD person in the sense
of knowing the numbers game of golf now
I want to try to hit a certain number
okay you know when you play golf the par
is 72 usually I don't mean 18 you're
trying to get to and with golf it's low
numbers are better low is the best the
that each hole is like 3 to 5 right
that's what it was in the video 100%
yeah and there's gonna be there's going
to be 4 holes that are par 3
okay on a golf course and there's gonna
be four holes that are par-5 and then
the rest are gonna be par 4 okay and for
any listener who is unaware of what that
means if a gulf course is 72 par 72 it
means it should take you seven eight two
times 72 attempts at contacting the ball
with the club to complete the course
okay I wonder why it was called par yeah
I don't know I don't know what that even
means this is because it every time you
take a swing at the ball that's counts
as a swing as a stroke yes a stroke and
a par is how many strokes it should take
you or or ideally would take you to get
to the hole in the ground yep where the
ball goes
yep so if it's a party I want that
written in like how to golf established
hole in the ground not a nature created
hole not a gopher random mother nature
cannot be involved in the creation of
where this ball is meant to go
no the Scottish would not approve hole
number one yeah how long is an average
of first of all I'm willing to bet that
most first holes on most golf courses
our it's a part probably a par four okay
not all the time but I would say the
majority probably is and it is probably
depending on which T you play from so
they have a golf course will sometimes
have a black tee blue tea white tea and
red tea what also a junior tee box okay
so this is the tee box so it's like if
you show up and you're like I am playing
from the blacks it is like that means
you are great okay that's like skiing
the black diamond yeah yeah it is like
oh I am I'm great at golf that means I'm
gonna play every single hole I play this
is the maximum distance this hole could
be okay playing is far away right Blue
is like him I'm pretty good at golf
I shoot pretty well this will be a
challenge
I am I play from like the white tees and
all the time
white is the is the one right above
junior it's probably it's actually so
the red tees are for women and then the
junior tees children what happened
let's get it let's get a boat I will say
it is it is kind of the it it is it's so
interesting when I am golfing yeah to
think that okay here's the black tee
blue tea white tea red tea junior tea
okay and what I saw is interesting is
that the red tee is just so specifically
known as the women's tees like
completely based on anatomy of like
muscle and right women will enjoy this
game if they need to you from here it's
just so funny to me that's like here
children should play from here yes
women should play from here men here are
three options where do you think you're
at when you stand not do it like you
step up to the tee box and think of well
what is the political correctness of how
this tee box should be saying but when
you step up you're like well that is so
so strange that it wouldn't just be
right yellow red white blue black what I
think you can accomplish exactly like it
like if they opened it up to that it's
um it would probably I mean women might
grow because there is I mean clearly
there is upper body strength and there's
some
illogical stuff going on yeah but I I
know that there are women who who should
start at a blue tea or whatever that you
know yeah and dudes that insist on
starting in a blue tea they should start
of the red tea or I ever I was one of
those people I was like I play from the
blues everybody played from moola I play
from the Blues and it wasn't till I
started playing with my father-in-law
every now and then we would play from
the white tees and he was like you know
he's like I play from the whites I'm not
gonna I want to enjoy the day what
occurred to me I was like yeah I also
want to enjoy this why am i why am i
someone who is learning and incredibly
average yes challenging myself as though
someone who gets it right I still don't
get it
so why am I putting myself in the
position of having to be great right
you're competitive with a mythological
being inside that's lurking on top of
Uranus what it is and that also is a
stranger than if that brings up
interesting point too is that the other
thing I enjoy is that you are only
competing with the golf course and
yourself even if you were in a
tournament against a hundred people yeah
you're it's who plays this course the
best so it's not like even if you are
you and I were playing really well it
wouldn't be oh I beat Jackie right it
wouldn't be exactly beat me it would be
lost
yeah i won yeah it would be oh I was
able to play this course in this many
strokes right and Jackie was able to
play this course in this mini stroke and
the beauty of it is that we could then
be like let's play 18 more and it could
be beyond the opposite okay right could
be like well actually I won by 20
strokes it's like yeah I lost by that
maybe and I just want I just won yeah
four hours ago I won right yeah and so
there are many many questions have come
to mind one of which is I wrote down
which is how do you warm up like if it's
the if the first thing is is a par four
yeah that's not the easiest well it's is
it a par four by the way from the black
tea and from yeah tea
okay yeah yeah all of it is saying it
this is from this point you're saying
you want to play all the course from
this distance and some of the tea box
just means it's slightly closer and yeah
and it's just they've just shortened the
distance the start
because you're new or whatever and also
when you look at a scorecard
it does list all those colors and then
it tells you the total yardage of the
entire course okay so it's like if
you're gonna play from the Blues today
yep
you might be playing a five to six
thousand yards in the doors okay whereas
if it's the others and you might there
could be a part of you that's like yeah
I don't I don't really want to cover
that kind of distance 3,000 yards or
whatever and and obviously a tee box is
at every it's at every hole that's the
starting point yeah but so every hole
that starts over right black at the
furthest point white or junior at the
closest point yeah okay and then okay so
and how do you warm up you I don't do
this and I need to learn how to and and
it I feel like if I had grown up playing
golf or took any lessons there be a
coach who may have explained to me the
best way to do this but an intense
stretch because you are working so much
of your back muscles yeah that just for
the safety of your own health shoulder
yeah and just the the back thing just so
core to your entire function of your
body it's like I should stretch but so I
do that or and also I should be on the
range the driving range forwarding
certain clubs yeah so I'll like just to
get the feel of like how am i hitting
them all today reminding yourself how to
hit the ball remind yourself how your
hands should be holding the club where
your how your feet should be set right
um cuz with every club also and this
will be hard as a visual for blisters
but when you're standing you know to the
side of the ball that you're about to
hit yeah you know the where that ball is
sitting in your stance
you know if it's my driver I might have
the ball here and my if this is my left
leg I've got the ball further up in my
stance and then if I'm adding a pitching
wedge I might be standing here so that
the pitching wedge comes through here
okay little listener to know that what
you're doing is you're you're moving
your where your feet are to line up
either with the ball or Center from the
ball Center from the ball or in front of
the bar a little behind
the angle of the club hits it correctly
right so that you're pointed in the
right direction and when it does it'll
aid the where you hit it will aid going
in that direction yeah and I think
learning the game of golf yeah as you're
as you're starting to learn at the point
that I'm at is it's so mental because
it's like you don't just grab a club and
step up and hit the ball the same way
every time you do have to go alright
well I'm hitting this degree wedge and I
know that I hit this wedge anywhere
between a hundred and a hundred and
thirty yards yeah that pin is a hundred
and twenty yards so I need to hit this
maybe a hundred and ten yards and hard
and then rolls the remaining
okay ten or remaining five is right but
then also on top of that while you're
doing that math if you then forget where
you should have the ball in your stance
yeah all that math is it couldn't just
be out the window and I've been useless
okay and are there several now you're
talking about the the degree of the
wedge is it are there more than one
wedge yes yeah okay there's different
degrees you will technically should only
have fourteen clubs in your bag that is
like the USGA rule right if you were in
tournament yeah pick forty you can have
any fourteen you want you just cannot
have more than forty stick you could
have a ha so 14 clubs there's wood right
the woods so the drivers yes your driver
and your fairway woods okay so those are
for your greater distance you know
you're your driver being the Club you're
hitting off of a tee to really get some
distance right yeah to really set you up
for your re there's my first time
hitting the ball I really want this to
go as far toward the hole as poss as
possible there you go however yeah and
this is what's fun that you may find
yourself as a person who's like you know
I am great whenever I hit the ball at a
hundred and fifty yards I'm very
accurate okay you might find at a
hundred yards you're not as accurate
mm-hmm so there might be a part of you
it's like well what is the math from
this the tee box
yep what club do I need to hit to get it
to a hundred and fifty yards out so that
my next shot
I'm hitting that club so you might not
use your driver every time depending on
your strength right okay so but basic
first hole basic hole is isn't it
usually like 320 yards yeah it can be
dependent like I said depending on those
tee boxes but also I would say a normal
like par 4 it's probably safe to say
like 400 400 yards yards so if you could
if you could use a wood and knock at 300
yards yeah but you have to worry about
accuracy but let's yeah let's say you
are like I know I can hit my driver 300
yards yeah but I'm not so great with
hitting my wedge a hundred yards oh but
I am great at hitting my 8-iron a
hundred and fifty yards so there might
be a part of you goes well if I want to
get to 150 I need to drive the ball 250
yards okay maybe then you don't hit your
driver because you plan your next move
exactly like in chess especially you're
trying to figure that out because as
you're learning you'd like to think that
you're getting better which means oh
you're probably hitting the ball better
you know as time goes on you're probably
hitting it straighter which means all
the math that you've learned about your
clubs yeah is now changing okay now
you're actually hitting it straight now
you're actually now you're that you're
like oh I'm hitting it confidently
straight I think I can swing a little
harder I think I can get a little bit
more muscle and it's like that changes
your whole it's almost like you delete
you almost have to delete the entire
algorithm and say I'm gonna now create
new right yeah holy crap
okay well that is that is fascinating
actually so those are the woods are also
called drivers right no you just have
the driver and then they're just called
woods like fairway woods oh really and
those are like a three wood and a five
wood and all of those numbers are just
basically they just kind of basically
coincide with the degree of the of the
the angle of the club so that you it it
kind of informs you of the distance
you've probably hit it right it's just a
reminder right and and is there a
standardized from Club to club like from
different manufacturer
of clubs like does everyone know a
3-wood has that degree you know that's a
good question I know that drivers you
can get a driver that's like nine and a
half degree maybe you can go lower than
that I haven't seen that but right I'm
sure that that's out there and then you
know I have my grandfather's old driver
and it's an eleven and a half not a lot
of people would be like I would never
use an eleven a half because I'm really
I don't want it to go as high I'm really
trying to get it far okay the driver
that I currently use is a ten and a half
okay
degree but then I'm assumin very for the
woods too but I actually just don't know
that right so when you go in to buy golf
clubs like if you want to buy your own
golf clubs you know like you have to be
aware of what number degree you're good
with yep or you have to make a
commitment to get good with yeah when
you get those clubs well the the one
thing that is consistent maybe it isn't
so much in the driver in the woods but
like the irons I think are all the same
degree so if this is an 8-iron I would
assume that all the brands the degree of
that 8-iron is exactly the same look at
as they set that's that number that's a
knob in our own the irons even numbers
in the woods no they're all it's a most
irons it's usually like four five six
seven eight nine okay yeah okay so you
buy those like separate like if you were
gonna go buy clubs like right now yeah
you would buy the driver that you like
you would buy the fairway woods that you
like you would buy the irons that you
well the irons are the only ones that
usually you can buy every single Club
individually yeah most people will buy
like a set of iron's okay um I would say
the people who probably don't are either
pretend this is kind of crazy because
they're almost on opposite ends of the
spectrum people who don't buy them all
together are probably so Pro they know
exactly what they want yeah we're so new
and just looking for a bargain that
they'll just buy them individually right
which is so crazy that the the
consistency of those buyers they
couldn't be on further ends of the spec
what about a garage sale yes
exactly I'll try to figure out that's
three dollars you got it you got it I'll
try to play with that that Club can you
play with one club you can you could
play the entire course with just one
club if you so desired right yeah
recommended there's a few tin cup
Oh ten Cup playing yeah yeah there the
people have recommended their like if
you want to get really good with like
your 7-iron yeah they're like go play
the hole you know except for maybe
pudding but go play the entire course
with just your 7-iron because then
you're just hitting that one club over
and over and over again and you're
having to adjust how hard right you hit
it and stance and I'll just dance and
everything yeah Wow
well how far does a seven club go do you
think for me it goes about a hundred and
anywhere between 160 and 170 yards okay
Wow within ten yards yes and you people
usually calculate they usually say like
I can hit my 8-iron 150 so then the math
is like unless you know it exactly which
I don't write but the math is like 10
yards as you go up so like an 8-iron I
can hit 150 a 7-iron actually hit 160
6-iron 170 okay and so on and so on and
then it's because I'm not so accurate
right it's almost like I could hit my I
get stuff up and be like I'm gonna now
hit my 8-iron 150 yards because that's
what I need to do and then I hit it 40
yards and I'm like that was awful what's
great though cuz you have the TV but
golf voice for a second I am now going
to I will now embarrass myself in front
of anyone
watching me do this there are certain
people that you golf with a lot of
comics I actually yeah there's a lot of
comics who golf that it's fun to go out
with I I'm getting my like wife into
playing okay divorcing it really
important really as a person who never
played board games before I got married
yeah I am familiar and I love board
games now yeah yeah but I think she
enjoys it um we go to the range and I
tell her every time I'm like I think I
can help you learn how to make contact
with the ball but just as a disclaimer I
don't necessarily know what
right and she's at a point now where she
I think she is a natural at the game
okay which is kind of great to see
because I like I said I'd really don't
know what I'm talking about I don't know
why I'm able to do what I do I think I
just had good advice from various people
right as I played so I try to like take
all that that I've heard other people
tell me and try to like communicate it
to her and I think she just kind of gets
it because she she's very good well I
mean I think from what you're describing
of this game it sounds like if you have
a good eye
you know like depth perception and
pretty good eyesight and a pretty good
judge of not hand-eye coordination but I
distance coordination yep
if and those are those can be taught but
I think that there's also a natural
aptitude yeah so she might have that
yeah again somebody that's interesting
also is that you know there I've seen
this every now and then like two or
three people who are completely blind
who play golf and if they're if they do
have the ability to understand where the
ball is and I'm going to hit the ball
mm-hmm
then the interesting thing about it is
that is definitely the hardest part
because if someone's like well they
can't see the hole it's like but if
someone is there to say yes you're in
the right position and yes you are aimed
at the hole right then it really is mad
it might never be a bigger math thing if
you tell the right blind person you are
faced in the correct and and then they
live I don't know if you know this about
blind people superpowers you can fly and
that's why they're better and because it
is such a you know if if they were like
alright you're facing the right
direction yeah you need to hit it 150
yards
that's exactly how far away this then
that person without needing to see the
hole if they truly have been told
they're aimed at the right there might
be like well then give me this club
because I will now hit that Club
right and it that's a learned skill
right where they're like the first time
they do that they're like oh well I
obviously hit that too hard because now
it is 200 yards away yeah and but but as
as a blind person would get better
pointed in the right direction much like
everybody else who was human yeah they
would learn to adjust for whatever
exactly yeah and I don't know I guess I
ever looked it that way
no no I just seen it like in like on TV
on TV and and magazine I get a magazine
I get a magazine blind offers monthly so
that one is and it's only a few people
in every single every single issue I
think I remember seeing blow by blow of
the four people that are blind and that
happened to be famous we're just
following them monthly I I think I'm
like a news clip of a blind golfer
getting a hole-in-one on a par three
okay I mean there I am more than likely
not going to end the majority golfers
will never ever do that a par one just
getting a hole-in-one on a park and it's
insanely crazy I mean even when you see
a professional golfer someone who hits a
thousand golf balls a day yeah when they
do it you see them also go crazy because
then the person of the highest level
it's like this is insane
yeah this just happened and then see a
blind person do it right you're like
that is it it's so bizarre
it's bizarre to know that that's capable
without what you would assume is such an
it so let's not kill time because they
it turns out we need them to do this for
I need them inspire us all or in
themselves so how often do you golf now
I mean if you're not working every day
because it's ok because you were
bitching comics a lot of comics get work
yeah because club owners golf yep and
then all of a sudden I'm like when I
could take up golfing I did something
different I took up Magic the Gathering
yeah I and the 90s because the Booker
played that yeah I do kind of wish I had
taken up golf because there's a bunch of
club there's a bunch of clubs that you
can get work at yeah a bunch of clubs
and I played at the Charlotte comedy
zone okay Aviva done they're open for
Maria there oh yeah okay so Mike Hall
the the manager there yeah he's a golfer
and he has friend who golf's and so we
went and played a course
today's a certain number to like is
three a good number to go golfing with
or is it you know usually usually four
is the max there's some courses that let
you play in a group of five but it also
can be miserable to play with too many
people because you're waiting there is a
timing to the game where you don't want
to be the people behind you you want to
you know as if there's a group in front
of you they've hit their tee shots yeah
and now they've cleared the tee box to
go hit their second ball so now you have
taken over the tee box and the etiquette
is that after they have now hit their
second shot that's that should go far
enough to the point where when you hit
your tee shot
you couldn't possibly hit hit them or
get near them so you should go ahead and
hit and then it just kind of moves right
like when do you yell for I yell it when
when I hit the ball and it goes way
further left or right than I intended
and I'm usually yelling it towards
people that are on a different like I so
sorry yeah but every single golfer has
had to yell it and has had a ball coming
at them to the point where you truly
would only get upset as a golfer if a
ball landed near you and someone didn't
warn you where you're like hey the
etiquette is just yell fore so that I'm
like oh yeah I'd have braced for impact
yeah yeah so do not yell it you're kind
of like well now a ball could just that
I could have gotten out of the way yeah
you know it's just rude not yell for
right again we don't know where the word
for comes from yeah I also don't know
that yeah I don't know I feel like these
are all things like I'm sure there's
someone who knows and that will email me
at Jackie Jackie Kashian comm like the
origin of the word T coz that's that
little wooden thing you stick in the
ground that's also a good question yeah
and then you put the ball on top of it
yeah and then you got a it's not police
your brass it's do something with your
divots or something oh replace your
divots or that's a that's a golf term
right here when you play into a green
specifically if you're hitting a green
is the degree not a part the qanun green
and so to get to get onto the green
there is a good chance you are hitting a
wedge which has a
higher loft higher lob okay that should
be the case okay and the arc of the ball
cuz the way you hit it because of the
angle of the crime so I hit a 56-degree
wedge which means
oh that ball is gonna go pretty high up
and come down the result of which being
it's going to leave a dent
now the putting green oh because I'm
afraid because the height cuz it's
coming it's probably coming straight
down I mean not straight down but it's
gonna be at an angle it's gonna get
harder it's gonna hit harder and it's
gonna have some kind of an impact and so
the etiquette is just to and you have a
little divot repair tool okay the idea
is to go and then kind of fix that so
it's flat again it's a few seconds it's
dirt or something yeah you just kind of
poke around where the divot is and it
kind of brings the ground up and then
you just you just flatten it back out
with your putter okay and the idea is
that well now you've repaired that so
that you know if someone has to putt
they don't want that in there or it's
gonna ruin their putts you're just kind
of like hey I repaired that but I play
all the time and there's people who they
just leave those right those holes so
that's why when you see professional
golfers playing they'll once their ball
is down in there they're taking a look
at the line and how they're gonna putt
it you see them walk between the ball
and the hole analyzing so much because
they're looking for any any kind of
anything that's going to disrupt the the
the role of the ball so they're like
trying to make sure it's not gonna hit a
bump or a divot yeah sending it another
way yeah because at that level in that
competition you know all of those
strokes matter right so much there's
people that lose millions of dollars on
a weekend yeah because of one stroke
right cuz they didn't check exactly or
or they just you know just whatever
caused that extra stroke they then look
back and go for four days I caught had
an extra there is one one person who
could be like and I just cleared that
green a little bit more I might have
made that putt and then in order to
think about that for a long that knows
how much money that you know right right
I wonder if with golf it is like if it's
like stand up where the only thing that
could fix a bad golf game is a good golf
game I think it is yeah I feel bad set
good set
even when you're playing bad golf which
I was doing yesterday I was playing
poorly but but you enjoyed it I did
enjoy because every now and then I was
hitting the ball well and I was just
like you know if I came out and I was
not hitting the ball well ever right
like that is the that's bombing where
the crowd wants you to die right but
getting it all right you're it's kind of
one of those things where you walk away
and you're like some of the crowd liked
it but I have to know that the the rest
of the crowd didn't hate me yeah I just
didn't do a good job of showing them I'm
better than what I did right it's a that
said is a learning experience I see what
I did there yeah that was a mistake I
also got paired up with an 83 year old
man yesterday so that that's another
thing I enjoy about golf is when I go
out by myself yeah to play just to you
know you go up to the you know if you
make a tee time or whatever if you're
alone there's no golf course that's just
going to let you play by yourself if
someone else is wanting to play they'll
put four strangers together
Oh real to be like hey there's a lot of
people that want to play and if we put
you all four together there's more so
it's all based on timing like certainty
times that are available yeah
tee times start they can start as early
as like 5:00 a.m. as long as there's Sun
as long as and not even that I mean that
I've gone out I've I've teed off at 5:45
before and the Sun wasn't even up and I
just kind of teed off into the dark and
played two holes in the dark and I only
did it cuz I was like well I want to
beat the rush hour and right and then
I'm done at 9:45 and it's like I still
have the whole day and I still got to go
play yeah four hours of golf does it
take four hours to play of an 18 hole
three I mean it can take even longer
depending on the traffic right there but
it should take you three to three and a
half to four and a half okay four is
like the standard you should get done in
four if you're not getting done in four
you're either playing extremely slowly
or people in front of you are playing
extremely slow right and there's nothing
you can do about that
can you play through that is also part
of the etiquette so if you're playing
extremely fast and you're behind me and
I'm not playing well and I just noticed
that every single time you're waiting I
see you like she's ready to tee off and
I'm hitting the ball
in the fairway right the etiquette is
for me to like you know from a distance
like kind of give you the come on
through and then you just play the hole
and I just kind of stand aside until
you're you've gone through and then I
play I've taken my two shot yeah and
it's more taxing to let people do that
yeah hey we're playing so fast behind me
it's like you're gonna enjoy the day
more if I just let you go cuz your pace
is way different than what it's a half a
date we're talking it's a long time more
day it's a four hour yeah event I mean
but I mean also if you want to warm up
yeah it's more than four hours I mean I
in times its if I want to go go up I try
to give myself an hour okay or so or in
I also have to get up you know like I
can play super early so don't you have
children I do so that's why going that's
why I can only go on Thursday and Friday
that's when we have a nanny the job here
we should watch our child so on so if I
play like 6:30 in the morning yeah I'm
gonna try to get to that golf course
about 5:45 okay just like it warm up but
you know because you want to putt a
little bit you know read the read the
green a little bit see sometimes there
the greens are so thin or super dry that
the ball moves very quickly sometimes
they're really slow so you kind of want
to find out like alright well what do
the Greens gonna probably be like okay
what about astroturf does anyone ever
play on astroturf er is it always real
grass well a lot of driving ranges you
tee off on mass which is similar to yeah
to playing like that like turf but
that's just a first shot but well no
that's just the driving range for like
warming up I don't reckon I'm een that's
the majority because that's the cheapest
and I see also California a lot of
public courses and because of the
drought it's like hey we're a public
course we're not charging a ton of money
yeah and also there's a drought so we're
not watering the driving range we're not
gonna make sure it's you don't care
you're just going for your practicing
distance I only I start to care now
because I realized that it's pretty bad
for your elbows because when you're
hitting off the grass to warm up yeah if
you go way under the ball you're still
kind of going through and you're just
gonna live you know is there's grass
whereas astroturf is gonna be pushing
back against your club yeah there's
resistance
so you're not when you go out on the
course it's like you're not going to
have that resistance so if you're
counting on it yeah you're screwed okay
yes yeah that's a learned if you if you
do the drink-driving arrange a lot yeah
and then you try to transfer that to
that do the yeah I can definitely change
your your your distance and how your
style of hittin them how much is a
bucket of balls these days 50 balls at
the Van Nuys golf course is six dollars
six bucks that's not bad I don't think
so
I remember when I was a kid my dad would
take us and I think was like two or
three bucks for a bucket of balls yeah
and he was like you could have a bucket
of balls on that kind of guy here's a
weird Club that that's okay and and so
how often do you try to go like once or
twice I try to go once or twice a week
if I can because I I growing up as an
athlete playing a lot of sports and now
being 35 I still go play basketball I
still play soccer but okay you know as
nature would have it my recovery from
those physical activities is way longer
yeah so there's a part of me it's like
oh I definitely can't play soccer or
basketball into my 70s but you know I
just played yesterday with an eight golf
with an 83 year old man well well I mean
it you could tell he's played his whole
life just have the ability at 83 but it
just goes to show you oh you can Golf is
a sport you can play you can keep later
in life and enjoy you know did you play
nine or I just played nine he was
playing more but it was kind of a slow
of course there were a lot of people in
front of us okay
a lot of chitchat between him and I on
the tee box and we had to wait for quite
a long time you get to you get to hear
the history of that guy got the eyee on
all of it I got this Los Angeles
I guess the history of that guy has he
been in Los Angeles for motor born in
Hollywood oh good lord
girl born in Hollywood it's super great
guy you know that
it sounds weird but I never played golf
with my grandfather right I don't even
know if this guy has grandchildren I was
like but here we are in a grandfather
grandchild situation at
is innocent and I know that we're both
not like thinking about that as we're
golfing but it's like you're an absolute
stranger yeah and we are now going to
spend just the two of us too because
we've a nine holes we're going to spend
two hours together right playing a game
two people who have never met we will
never talk ever again next two hours
yeah we are partners in this game of
golf yeah and it's an it's sort of like
a it's a that is it's like a an old guy
like like getting a generational kind of
moment yeah it's a little slice of well
now we went to one of our neighbors died
we went to the funeral and we're
standing next to she was very old and we
said we were standing next to a very old
man at the funeral and it was over at
Forest Lawn over in Burbank and he said
you know the old cuckold guide says to
Andy and I you know you can't be buried
in this in Forest Lawn in in Forest Lawn
graveyard if you live in Burbank and
we're like what why is that and he goes
well you know if you're alive in Burbank
they're not gonna bury it and I was like
wow that is some graveside humor my
friend that is that guy was genuinely
like late eighties I think we weren't
his first funeral he has sharpened that
bit over a number of funerals
I don't know these two I'm gonna throw
him the the a stuff first
whoopsie why not yeah B we will become
free yeah why would I throw them the
CIMA to I can lose them
I could lose them completely they don't
know me I'm not even gonna say my name I
haven't even been introduced
Andy has been telling that joke ever
since like a week and any opportunity
scraps will bring up that joke oh I love
that I love that so much yeah so let's
talk more about golf here's my next
question yes
what do you have you done a lot of
different courses oh can I had there was
something I was going to say oh yeah
please but so too in talking about not
being able to play soccer and basketball
yeah I don't know that I would care so
much about the
provement as a golfer man granted I have
been bitten by the bug and I am an
addict and because it's all about making
your score less and less and I have sort
of an OCD about that right like when I
play Galaga yes it isn't so much like oh
I'm loving Galaga it's like there's a
perfection to wanting to clear the
universe of all these space bugs
spaceships in my head I'm like I am
exterminating flying bugs and I am going
to and I'm in there's something about
best job ever yeah those type of video
games suck me in more than any video
game ever yeah and took off is similar
of like trying to get to perfection and
trying to achieve it and being in the
business that we're in
yeah there is the opportunity to play
with professional golfers in pro-am
tournaments right for charity so
charities and you usually play on a
Wednesday Tuesday or a Wednesday before
they play their real tournament yeah and
there's you can not that this is always
the case or that you'd never get invited
but if you fall into the category of
celebrity would you and I both know can
be from is such a huge range that is
that is a line graph and and and I don't
know that they are so not every single
tournament is like let's get a list
celebrities they might not even be able
to get c-list celebrities I was a
celebrity on a on a charity D&D game
yeah over over in Indiana Pathfinder
sure I didn't even know that existed no
me neither and little did I know nobody
knew is that a circuit of things it was
the thing that they do for charity it's
a pathfinder that's it was really fun
yeah anyway um have you got so it's
similar to that it's sort of someone
saying we think you're a celebrity so if
you're invited yeah and they say Jackie
we want you to come and play D&D mm-hmm
so there's a part of you that goes am I
good at this will I embarrass myself
that I won't win this or will I but will
I be the worst so with golf I'm the same
thing I go well if someone to say
hey you're on a TV show or hey we know
your stand-up yeah so we want you to
come and you know you end up playing
with people who paid to play with the
celebrities Tago interest charity and
you you just need to be entertaining so
for me it's like oh I would love to go
and joke around I just don't want to be
so bad so in my head I'm like if I can
get myself to very average yeah I'll
probably play just like the people I'm
paired up with right and if I'm making
jokes and they're finding it
entertaining and it you know if if I'm
so fortunate that they would recognize
me because then they would actually
enjoy it more
then the laughs even harder so there's a
part of me wants to get better because
that opportunity is actually realistic
it's like oh because I'm in
entertainment I could get to play you
could in a professional setting where
I'm never going to be a professional
golfer but this is the closest I can get
so there's a part of me it's like oh I
should strive for that because I do
enjoy it and you know some of these
things they fly you in they put you up
and right because we do stand-up it's
like well hey what if I did a show
Saturday night they might be like great
so yes let's get you here let's yeah
yeah you perform it ya know so I have no
idea how realistic everything I just
said is for me as an opportunity but I
know that ready for it yes I know that
if like I'm decent at golf then if if
things take off of my career it's like
if someone said hey there's this the
celebrity pro-am golf tournament then
I'm like 'men position we're like oh
maybe they would be happy to have me
yeah and I know how to play golf there
you go yeah well which is what the
Pathfinder thing is because it's
essentially it does spin off it does
it's like D&D but it's a different core
group or whatever right core mechanics
and I was like yes I will I will be in
your celebrity Pathfinder game because I
know what that lace sheet looks exactly
yeah I won't completely embarrass myself
which and you'd be and you know in your
heart you're like if I showed up and I
don't know and I just ride the fact that
I'm a celebrity they will hate me they
will hate me yeah and so I showed up I
knew most of what I was doing and I was
funny yeah so those were my two times
yes she's doing exactly we watching
entertaining everyone as she doesn't
that's perfect yeah let's do that maybe
we raised 12 more dollars for the Red
Cross exactly but it was for the Red
Cross it was for yes so what about of
course so to have you have you tried to
do with different courses around Los
Angeles I played a bunch of different
courses there's uh there's when I go to
a bunch Balboa not too far from here
yeah Encino Balboa sure course they're
public courses and Balboa is pretty easy
so it's great for me to like get my
self-esteem up yeah not be too
challenged and then it's fun for me to
also be like alright let's go play a
place like Rustic Canyon which is gonna
be more expensive its weight in Moorpark
it's way out there okay but it's a way
more difficult course to be like alright
well how do I fare when it's not as
setup to succeed what are you trying to
challenge a fancy course over in Toluca
Lake off of the street that the
smokehouse is on it's a dead I know what
is this it's a rose and and right off
you know how like an olive yeah yeah
yeah smokehouse and then rose and then
there's an 18 hole golf course which is
a private club okay and it backs up into
Bob Hope's old house which has a three
hole golf course built into it right and
when I say house I don't mean house I
mean Bob Hope's whatever compound I mean
12 still lives there his wife still
alive I believe so yeah what do you did
he died at 101 I believe is that true
that is true I believe he lived to be
over 100 I don't know much about Bob
Hope other than golf fanatic and us oh
right well here stuff here's what I
learned I used to drink heavily over on
Lankershim and Moorpark there was a
place called the steak joint with a why
yeah and there's a big Catholic Church
there yeah and I was drinking there one
day and a guy told me so this is
anecdotal whether or not it's true about
Bob Hope is that the church that's
across the state drinks gone now but
that giant Church on what I believe to
be Lankershim and whatever Moorpark is
that guy called it the church that Bob
Hope's infidelity built
deal with his wife because she was
Catholic and he was Church of England
yeah that every time he cheated on her
he had to donate to that church yeah
that church if you ever drive by it made
of gold it's made of gold there's an
auditorium attached to it there's a
basketball court is a school
professional they have a professional
basketball team they're across the
street from it there's a community
center and then from there she was like
now you have to donate an airport and he
really cheated a lot eight across from
where they're they're their compound he
thing is there was a an empty lot that
that guy told me also that she kept that
empty lot as hers right and she was
gonna build a convent oh really
and just recently like three or four
months ago maybe six months ago they
broke ground they're building McMansions
there and so he's dead yeah she's like
well I can't hold that over the greatest
stories of Hollywood that's the only one
I know but he has supposedly a three
horse golf course a three horse horse
three hole golf course I love that well
I'm great with that in that say yeah I
thought about that yesterday when I was
sitting there with my new best friend
here's 83 right we were just sitting
waiting for the group in front of us I
was like if you had one if you had one
hole at your house that was like 400
yards you would become so great at golf
yeah I think you would because you know
over and over and over again you would
be like you would build the confidence
of how to play right holy I'm gonna now
drive the ball I'm a now how this hit
this nut because if it's your own hole
and you can practice on as much you want
yeah you can set the ball at any
distance and work on that distance yeah
alright cuz you can work on the distance
yeah and be like oh that's the whole
game to some extent is being able to
judge how far you could hit the ball
right and you want to be sore like
through for a par four if you're ever
watching golf and they say greens and
regulation that means on a par four it
should take you two shots to be on the
green on the putting green
the putting green two shots to get to
the green two shots are five it's three
okay so the reason why no golfers do
when they get really wowed by distance
Tiger Woods for instance that's a guy
who when he plays a par-5 there is a
very good chance he is going to be on in
two shots on a par five meaning that he
is he's yeah that if he's a good putter
yeah it's like he's gaining even that
many strokes yeah for who he's competing
with and it's like and his consistency I
mean are the Greens multitude of reasons
why he's great but that consistency is
why you see someone like him winning
over and over and over and over it's
like oh he has sheer power to gain
strokes yeah in a situation the greens
are all different okay and every single
if there's a tournament at a golf course
and it's gonna be four days Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday each day they are
going to move where the hole is on each
green to a different location and a lot
of tournaments Sunday is when they put
it in like the toughest location on the
green yeah so hole number one yep or
let's go hole number six okay
hole number six each day in a four day
tournament and you have to play every
day for a tournament so if you're in a
tournament yeah you you are you're
playing your professional golfer yeah
you are playing on Thursday and you're
playing Friday okay and then on after
Friday's round half the field gets cut
okay you don't even play so the others
get to play all four days okay and I do
I haven't checked on this but this is
probably not right but maybe it is I
don't know if you don't make the cut I
think you don't get paid okay yeah so
there's a lot of kinda prorated yes
there's a there's sort of a reflective
world with how we operate and stand up
for instance when as you and I both know
when you're starting out if you get a
gig you then can't go well there's money
to spend you almost have to be like well
I might have to buy a flight for another
gig
where I'm gonna break even and if I keep
spending the money right on anything
other than necessity then I may ruin
that bank that goes toward stuff and
like golfers if you're unlike the
web.com or if you're low on the PGA Tour
it's a tour because you are going city
to city on weekends and if you're not
qualifying you're not making any money
and you're paying out of your caddy ten
percent so you when you see something
like 10 Cup and you're like oh he drives
his RV up and camps out at the at the
course like that's that's also what the
best golfer currently Jason Tay does
with his family he lives out of a camper
and drives to a lot of like place and I
he's at a point financially with
endorsements and winning where he
doesn't have to know
I probably stayed a Hampton Inn right
and you could finally get Hampton and
status who knows what their rewards are
re Lobby Wi-Fi let's not forget never
surrender yeah that's okay Wow so
they're not necessarily making money
yeah and they're playing for so if they
play Thursday and so if you play
Thursday and then you play Friday and
you are in the top half of the people
then you keep playing you get to keep
playing you play Friday and then is it
cut again nope just after two days
there's a cut and then two more days two
more days of play and so what dictates
that cut is let's say Thursday and
Friday everybody's now played two rounds
and the person who's winning is eight
strokes under par okay for two days okay
seventy-two par 72 have a 66 yeah yeah
up to 66 and but it's also like the the
sum of your scores okay so it's a part
of me too and you're like oh a 70 and
then I shot a 68 yeah so it's like okay
so you're six under par for the two days
yeah got it and it's sort of win a term
it's the total of its cumulative oh yeah
okay
and then so if they if the the leader
for the weekend is currently six under
the spectrum is now gonna be huge
there's gonna be someone at the bottom
who's plus 15 who's you had a nightmare
so based on that that spectrum that's
what dictates where the cut is
going to be so that on Friday that I
feel a sort of them because they're like
well that 6-under this many players were
able to be what you know all the way to
like even par so they might be like even
par as they so they don't cut it in half
it's not necessarily cut right in half
if there's thirty players as close to
half as possible but you want it to be
as close to half as possible okay and
what but but there is a give or take
based on how powerfully people fit into
the top scorer you there's only so many
slots available alright and a lot of
people there'll be nine people who
aren't even par yeah and you're like
well we can't have all of them you so if
the if the if the cut is par yeah that
means all nine they make it okay meaning
that you then go okay we have to
distribute the spots out accordingly and
the T times accordingly so on Thursday
at any and I don't know how interesting
and this part this part is very like
meticulous but on a Thursday at a
tournament there's so many golfers like
120 okay so that when they say all right
so the first group is gonna tee off at
7:00 a.m. okay that means four people
are gonna tee off on hole number one at
7:00 a.m. yeah and four people are also
gonna tee off on the 10th hole and play
the back nine to start because there's
so many people oh you gotta get like
this kind of rotation like this rewrite
going yeah get them out of the way and
then we might play the back nine first
front and then the front nine yeah and
then when you get to Saturday now you've
made the cut and you've got rid of half
now there's no longer groups of four
it's usually now groups of two okay yeah
and so sort of an exciting thing is that
on Saturday and Sunday the the final
group that's gonna tee off for
television purposes yeah is who's ever
in the lead under the assumption that
that's who we're gonna want to see on TV
all the way to the end right because
they're competing and so it makes it's
likely that's someone of one of those
two people or maybe the group before
them or the group before them is gonna
be a champion justifying why we're still
watching it right or auntie right and
and just to some extent on Sunday they
to two into it the top six players yeah
okay yeah because probably one of these
six people is gonna win ya know Kay's
gonna be teeing off like last
and that would be like probably like at
1:30 or 2:00 o'clock you watch a golf
until I watch every weekend every it is
when someone goes oh it's boring to
watch golf I 100% get I grew up playing
soccer so because I played soccer I
understood soccer I loved watching
soccer and I had to grow up in around
people who would be like this is so
boring the scoring is so ridiculously
low I absolutely hate this and I'm like
because you're just watching for points
I'm able to see the game the game that
is like happening outside of the points
the drama of the rest of it comedian
Gilbert lawan do you know him he was out
of it landing in that lives in New York
he made such a great point he's like do
you know if he's like if a soccer game
ends three two and people are like well
that's only five goals that happened
he's like yeah it's kind of like a
football game ending 21 to 14 but you
don't complain about that right but you
but but when people watch pro football
they're like I was I was only 2014 they
go oh but it was so much football was
played it's like it's the same in both
there's so much to watch still outside
of just the goal yes if soccer was seven
points a goal
would it be more exciting exactly Andy
has some he shares season tickets with
some friends to the galaxy oh yeah it
was a bunch yeah so he likes it I've
been to two games yeah by I don't know
what about it's that's the thing if
there's a sport that name that you
necessarily had to like play it but if
you don't know what to watch for yes and
then if someone even explains you what
to watch for
it doesn't even it doesn't mean you're
gonna like watching that aspect of it
right but so growing up with golf
because I never played it I didn't
really wake when my grandfather dad and
uncle when they would watch golf at like
family barbecues yeah I could not
understand how they could do it I was
like this is so boring is happening but
now that I've played and I understand it
I know what they were watching they were
looking for yeah they were you know
seeing a professional golfer hit a ball
from 200 yards away and land it within a
foot hole you now respect how difficult
that truly is to do and I'm a
professional golfer from 200 yards away
might land it a foot from the hole
because they hit it past
with backspin knowing it would then come
back towards the hole and you see that
you're like that is so in to be able to
do that yeah so incredible right that
you net now when you watch it there's
something you understand what the
entertainment truly is now right I
remember my dad watching it and just was
just soothing yeah it's just it's like
watching fish yeah I watch every every
weekend and now I know who'd like the
players are who to cheer for who I like
who is it pros is it is it I college
it's mostly pros I have I've watched
College when it's on I watched I watched
the men's PGA I wish the Women's LPGA I
watch College the web.com right tour
which is like the semi-pro you know okay
people that are on the web comm tour
those are people making very little
money and I think to qualify for a PGA
Tour card on that tour you have to win
two tournaments over that is insanely
difficult to do and then get to be in
the PGA is like you know that this is
their dream these are your golfers that
you know for the most part are out of
college yeah the golfed in college and
now they're like let's see if I can
become a professional golfer and like a
lot of pro sports there's gonna be a lot
of heartbreak you're not gonna make it
you're not gonna make it yeah a friend
of a friend of Andy's who were he went
to college with is about five or six
years ago started touring with golf okay
his name's Chris Winslow yeah and he has
won some tournaments and I don't know
this I don't know if he's on I sound
about want to do it he is this great
club that he does buddy I don't know you
might one day see the name Chris Winslow
yeah but it occurred to me at minute 59
I bet you he'd be a pretty good golf
dork to talk about I'm going to look
into his name for sure sure he's finally
find new names and and and share for the
under it's such a great sport to cheer
for the underdog too because it's such a
hard
yeah he's worm Phoenix and so it's I
mean have you ever gone to have you ever
played Arizona has a lot for a state
that has no water I want to do more I
want to
Raya to get to a point where I'm able to
take my golf clubs with me when I go out
on the road the only difficult thing is
I can only get yeah luggage but also I
can only justify in my head if I'm like
oh I have an hour together and I don't
really care I'm here to golf okay I
think in my head I think I've
established in my own mind that if I do
that too often I will then say I will
not accomplish any of my goals because
I've now just said oh I've made it to
the middle that's all I wanted to do now
let's enjoy retirement way too soon in
life I think that's what I'm convincing
myself what happen you know I open for
Bamford
and I was like anywhere you want to drop
me off by the way you're just because
she could skyrocket to the top right
still working to become super famous
yeah and I'm like I'm you just already
coattail to the middle and Rory Scovel
by the way is at Rory Scovel calm oh
wait it's a tree Scoble or it's Rory
Scovel calm yep and you have a tour in
September or that's when your next big
show I currently two things that cause
2016 yep I have a special that's out now
on Roy Scoville calm and this tour in
September that I'm doing I'm going to
shoot another special at the end of it
okay so I'm I decided I was like I'm
gonna go on the road and do some places
I've played before some places I haven't
been before all to just sharpen it all
up and get it ready so that I can shoot
it all at the end of September oh that's
great so yeah that's my my goal I'm
gonna do a new album in December
nice where are you doing it acne oh yeah
always but the Charlton special
Charleston special is the name of your
special available on Rory Scovel calm
yep
for download or streaming probably and
Rory Scovel this has been fascinating I
have learned yeah and it's been great
thank you so much for doing the show
thank you for having man letting me go
through the therapy of getting these
words out I'm sorry
the dark forest t-shirt that you are
getting for free is not a golf shirt hey
Rangers you know the rules take care of
each other out there my hat my hat my
hat they're dancing around my hat my hat
my hat my hat well what do you think of
that
if it looks like a Mexican Hat dance
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a Mexican hat so take off
your head and let's dance we why don't
we just call that at the end of the show